c'est parti tous les cartons déchets
doute arrêter les enfants de faire de la
merde
cette musique d'afrique oui c'est ça
qu'on veut voir aucune émotion comme ça
fume de vous est super content que super
tourne fort de cette politique chatoie
ce petit côté kawaii ans que j'ai changé
tu me tiens par contre patienter huit on
ne me verra justement d'une jambe tendue
de gens
vers 13 heures 10 ans et ça c'est ça
tu sais ça c'est ce qu'on leur tire peu
de karni john mois sérieuse au port qui
me peine en cacao type comme ça s'est
fait comme ça c'est fait aussi de la mer
j'ai plus le blue jay bleu métallique
j'aime le mar et un burger le botté de
manger durant possible on s'en bat les
couilles ont été installés chez nous
arrêtez les enfants de
plus vifs et amauri oui
aucune émotion de quoi ça rime ne vous
est pas super super contente c'est
toujours ce petit côté khawaja que j'ai
changé c'est vrai
primature par trois passionnés windows
2000 dans une jambe ou deux jambes je
vais retenir avant tout à fait sensé ça
c'est ça c'est ça ça peut pas faire du
tube can't be